[Music]
foreign
book in history no volume ever written
has been more loved and quoted and its
words sometimes simple and sometimes
mysterious should always be studied
carefully it is the Bible the word of
God welcome to Bible answers live
providing accurate and practical answers
to all your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast
call
800-835-6747 once again that's
800-835-6747 now here's your host from
amazing facts International Pastor Doug
Batchelor hello listening friends you
want to hear an amazing fact about the
world's longest walk George Megan a
former British sailor was the first
person to complete the Argentina Alaska
hike mostly on the Pan American Highway
beginning in 1977 at the southern tip of
South America it took me again
2425 days to complete the nineteen
thousand and nineteen mile walk to the
northernmost part of Alaska at prudo Bay
during those six and a half years he
took approximately 41 million steps he
wore out 12 pairs of Italian hiking
boots and he traversed the historically
impassable 66-mile Darien Gap where he
was shot at and survived a knifing
attack on scave
during his Epic Journey he secured eight
Guinness World Records
that's taking your life and just saying
I'm going to see how far I can walk and
you know you and I were talking before
the program not only did he walk you
know from the southern hemispheres
southernmost point I mean other than
Antarctica to the northernmost part of
Alaska when he got to Texas because he
started in the South he went North he
decided to see the east coast of the U.S
so he walked off the Pan American
Highway all the way over to the east
coast President Jimmy Carter met him
then he walked all the way back again
and resumed his journey up to Alaska so
he was a glutton for punishment and
along the way I should mention that his
Japanese girlfriend joined him he admit
while he was in the Navy and she would
join him for a little stints of it they
got married and he had two children
during the whole time he was walking
well you know the Bible says that living
your life the kind of life you live is
compared to a walk
and of course the first Psalm talks
about blessed is men who does not walk
in the way of the ungodly and then you
you've got the the scriptures that talk
about we want to walk in the spirit that
means living a life where we are
spiritually focused for instance
Galatians 5 16. I say then walk in the
spirit and you will not fulfill the
lusts of the Flesh and that means
keeping our eyes fixed on God communion
with God being aware of his presence
another similar verse Romans 8 4 that
the righteous requirement of the law
might be fulfilled in us who do not walk
according to the flesh but according to
the spirit so every day we're making
decisions how to walk
and it reminds me when um
Moses admonished Joshua and the children
of Israel for that matter he says you
know walk in the law of the Lord do not
turn to the right hand or the left and
so every day we're sort of going we're
walking and the the Hebrews use that
term to talk about the direction of your
life
and we want to have that Spirit-filled
life I think we have a free offer that
talks about we do absolutely uh the book
is called life in the spirit and it's
about how we can walk by faith day by
day following God's guide following that
narrow path that leads to to Heaven
we'll send it to anyone for free all you
have to do is call and ask the number is
800-835-6747 you can ask for offer
number one five five the book's called
life in the spirit you can also dial
pound 250 on your smartphone say Bible
answers live and then just ask for the
book by name it's called life and the
spirit we'll be happy to send it to you
if in Canada or in the U.S continental
U.S or Alaska if you're outside of North
America you can just go to our website
just
amazingfacts.org and you can go to our
library there and you can read the book
online
again we want to thank you for being a
part of this Bible study together Pastor
Doug and before we go to the phone lines
let's start with the word of prayer dear
father once again we are grateful for
the opportunity for the time to be able
to open up your word and study and Lord
we ask that your spirit we just spoke
about life in the spirit we ask that
your spirit would come and guide us in
our thoughts our words
as we search the scriptures Lord be with
those who are listening wherever they
are we ask this in Jesus name amen amen
all right we ready to go to our first
caller we've got Gary listening in
Illinois Gary welcome to Bible answers
live
in Luke 21 34 it says let not that day
of his coming be a surprise and so I'm
wondering why it would be a surprise in
Matthew 24 it says you'll see plagues
and pestilence wars and rumors Wars
earthquakes and that we see and we're
seeing tens of thousands of people
trying to escape Latin America you know
because climate change is so difficult
there and so why would it be a surprise
well it it clearly is going to be a
surprise for most of the world the Bible
says it's going to overtake most of the
world as a snare and Paul says to
Christians he said be awake be sober be
watching because you are not Children of
the Night that that day should overtake
you as a thief but for most of the world
you can read in the second Peter chapter
three it says the day of the Lord will
come as a thief meaning you know a thief
doesn't send a notice when he's coming
he comes when he's unexpected but most
of the world it's going to take them by
surprise and even Jesus said in such an
hour as you think not so the problems in
the world
um and I do think we're living near the
end don't misunderstand but this is not
the first time there's been Global
problems
so uh Jesus said it's still going to
surprise most people
you know we do have a study guide that
talks about the second coming of Christ
and talks about the signs of the soon
coming of Jesus it's called ultimate
deliverance and it's all about the
second coming we'll be happy to send
this to you Gary or anyone that is
listening just call and ask the number
to call is
800-835-6747 ask for the study guide is
called ultimate Deliverance it's all
about the second coming you can also
dial pound 250 on your smartphone and
ask for that by name uh ultimate
Deliverance you know and you made me
think uh reminded me that we also have
that sermon book he can read online
called anything but secret talks about
will there be signs will it be a secret
when Jesus comes a lot of people think
there's a secret Rapture before the
visible second coming and that book
explains that so why will so many people
be surprised he can just go to amazing
facts and read in our free book Library
anything but Secret
all right next holiday we have is June
listening in Nevada June welcome to the
program
hello pastors uh dog the best of John I
blessed evening to you my question is in
Matthew 7 7 to 1 and Jesus says not all
those who say the Lord Lord hear the
kingdom of God because Jesus says I do
not know you depart from me you're
always now the the live right of my
question is
um
is what is the meaning of Jesus he's
saying you are Lawless does that include
can you explain further does that
include uh the the right day of worship
well as part of being lawlessness yeah
and some people have a version that
would say
um crisis warning he said you know don't
think this because you say Lord Lord
he's going to declare to a lot of people
depart you workers of iniquity and in
the original Greek iniquity means a
lawlessness or sinfulness well it's
certainly when people are sinning
they're breaking the law
but that would not be restricted to
necessarily one commandment but it's
just a life of lawlessness but it would
certainly include people who know the
law and ignore it so
um there's yeah lawlessness is going to
be it's like Paul says in the last days
evil men and seducers will wax worse and
worse last days people will be
unthankful without natural affection
disobedient to their parents that's
lawlessness
all right very good next goal that we
have is Jerry listening in Texas Jerry
welcome to Bible answers live
hey good evening guys this is the first
time that I haven't seen you guys on
Amazing Facts it isn't on that you're
preaching right now in fact anyway my
Bible question refers to the exes uh
Journey we know that God took care of
his people and the cattle more than
likely ate Manna did uh this probably
refers to maybe Exodus 30 34 where did
they from get uh incense and wine from
Caravans that were traveling by the
camps of the children of Israel during
The Exodus period yeah and that's a
great question you know they weren't
growing grapes and you sort of have to
be stationary to have a Vineyard you
can't be wandering through the
Wilderness with your Vines so where did
they get some of these things that were
used you read in the second book uh
second chapter of Joshua in the exchange
between the spies and Rahab
um she says we have heard
they knew everything they knew not only
about what happened in Egypt it says
they knew about their winning their
battles with the amalekites uh or rather
the um uh OG and bayshan Kings across
the Jordan and so uh it's pretty clear
that there was a lot of trade going on
and then you read the ishmaelite Traders
are the ones who picked up Joseph they
went through the desert and sold them in
Egypt and so there were Caravans that
were trading and when you've got
customers where you got a you know a 200
or what do you call it they may have
been up to 2 million Israelites and they
did have gold when they came out of
Egypt so they had money to buy and they
had sheep to trade I'm sure that they
were just trading and buying some of
these things not everybody had
everything because they did complain
when they got hungry but they had enough
wine and incense for the temple and it
specifically mentions here in Exodus 30
it talks about frankincense we know that
frankincense was something that came
through the trade routes it wasn't in
the area of of uh where Israel was or in
the desert so there was some interaction
right with some of the trading groups
that came through good question uh Jerry
next one that we have is Joan calling
from Australia Joan welcome to the Bible
answers live
hello thanks for taking my call I just
got a question
um there seems to be a debate on whether
duck is clean or unclean can you please
help yeah um you know from my research
I've come to believe that uh geese and
swans and duck which are all in the same
family are not in the clean category the
only foul that we're clean to eat or
what you would call foraging foul and
they've got the you know the the feet
like a chicken turkey pigeon uh they
don't have webbed feet like a seagull or
a duck or a swan or a goose and you know
those animals often they rub around in
the muck a lot of a pond and a lake so
uh I I know I even have Jewish friends
that would disagree with me but then
there are Jew Jewish friends who do
agree with me so I do not believe that
duck were clean and
I was thinking when in doubt do without
I mean
not too many people are going to die
because they don't get enough duck to
eat but but yeah I think Duck's unclean
all right very good thank you appreciate
that John uh we do have a study guide
that talks about God's free health plan
is what the Bible says is uh good stuff
to eat and what you don't want to eat
and we'll be happy to send it to anyone
who calls and asks the number again is
800-835-6747 and you can ask for the
study guide It's called God's free
health plan one of the amazing facts
study guides also you can just dial
pound 250 on your smartphone say Bible
answers live and then say God's free
health plan we'll be able to send that
to you you know I was thinking and I I
was looking it up Leviticus 11 18 in the
Swan and the Pelican and the Gear Eagle
are unclean It also says that in
Deuteronomy 14 6 that's trying to find
the verse that's for Jones question
about duck so if Swann are unclean then
probably geese and duck are unclean
thank you next caller that we have is MK
listening in Iowa MK welcome to the
program
thank you
um
there's a few members of our um of our
church that we've gone to the Head
Deacon and we've gone to the pastor over
the kids of running and making so much
noise in the sanctuary during the sermon
and this week the pastor scolded the
congregation for complaining about this
and he said he didn't see a problem with
the noise in the sanctuary he said we
don't come to church for God that we can
do that in our own closet we come to
socialize with one another how do we
um deal with no reverence in the
sanctuary
that's a good question now first of all
I don't want to I don't want to get into
a debate with your local pastor but I'll
tell you the Bible does tell us that
when we come before the Lord to worship
him there should be reverence now let me
say something I don't want to make this
over overly complicated a lot of
churches use what you would call a
multi-space facility for their worship
service it's becoming more and more
common that uh you know churches are
sometimes used once a week and so people
have started using like a multi-purpose
room or building or they rent a
multi-purpose room and you know it might
be used for school during the week and
it's used for a church service or so
forth and people some have church in
their home
what we do is we let people know that
when we enter into the worship service
on Sabbath we should especially be aware
of God's presence it's a holy day it's a
place that's set aside for Holy purpose
and there should be reverence there now
that doesn't mean you can't greet
someone and say we're glad to see you
and you want to make visitors feel
welcome but you're right you know kids
should be taught and my wife and I I
think we've got a reputation in our
church for
telling the kids please don't run stop
right they're going to plow into some of
the old folks and hurt them because kids
get excited and they got all this energy
pent up and but uh yeah parents need to
watch their kids and you know Pastor
you're right it's it's a it can be a bit
of a challenge we're going to keep
reminding folks and uh we want to be
balanced you know we we don't want to
become a place where people feel afraid
to to greet the person sitting next to
them but we do want to have a spirit of
reverence and I think that is important
making that clear uh how we go about
that well I think each church needs to
consider what can be done I know we've
spoken about in our church especially as
the church has grown there are special
times where we want to bring people's
attention quiet things down focus on
what's Happening uh and so it's a it's
an ongoing work
and because we tape our services every
now and then I mean this is different
from what um was just being asked but um
you know sometimes a baby will cry
and that's normal but you know a lot of
churches have a mother's room where you
can take them out and they have to learn
it takes time to teach kids to you know
learn to sit still and give them
something healthy to do to keep them
occupied but they certainly shouldn't be
running around the sanctuary during the
services
all right next holiday we have is Dave
listening in Alaska Dave welcome to the
program you're on the air
thank you
um quick question basically I this was
inspired by a caller a couple weeks ago
and I didn't get on get in the show on
time
because I've got a mental illness
anxiety depression and others
that were really triggered when I became
a Christian about 30 years ago okay
here's the question here's the concern
summed up during the end time in
Revelation when there's the close of
Probation and we have no intercessor in
heaven
praying for us do we have to worry about
being lost by accidentally sinning
no
Because by the time that happens and
Pastor us correct me but by the time
probation closes the saved are saved and
the lost or lost so it's not even have
to worry about sinning
um you know when just think of it this
way once we get to heaven
will we need Jesus to intercede for our
sins in heaven well no because we've
been transformed we've got new hearts
and we're gonna have no desire to sin
and we're not going to need an
intercessor well the Lord is bringing
that about before he comes back his
people are going to be sealed with the
Holy Spirit and they're going to have
the Seal of God that's in his law as
well and we're I think we're not going
to have any desire to sin you know when
probation closes uh there is the verse
that we're reading revelation 22 where
Jesus says he that is Holy let him be
holy still he that is filthy let him be
filthy still so when probation closes I
one group has the Seal of God the other
group is the mark of the beast they have
made up their mind their faith has been
tested they have been proven to be
faithful to the Lord and God in a
special way with the holy spirit will
will guide his people and they'll be
secure yep all right well thank you for
your uh call there appreciate that we've
got uh lee listening in Texas uh lee
welcome to Bible answers live
yes pastors hello my question is
um is the mark of the beast both
spiritual as well as it is physicals
because when the market of the Beast is
in force and people do accept it those
that take it anyway
have like some kind of a bar code or
card or something that's proof that
there among that they actually do I'm
gonna have the seal okay
uh yes and no now what I mean by that is
because there'll be a law that you can't
buy or sell
will the government or the world powers
be using some kind of harder recognition
or uh you know they I don't think
anyone's going to have a barcode stapled
to them it's going to be internal in who
you worship and the works you do that's
why it's the hand of the forehead your
thoughts your actions worshiping the
Beast either in worship or in Behavior
but when it comes to the buying and
selling it wouldn't surprise me if they
use some kind of technological card or
device or one of those RFID inserts I
don't know what they'll use but they'll
do something to you know measure it
right now they don't even need that they
have facial recognition that is so
sophisticated artificial intelligence
you know in China now people are going
through school and they're checking
their tenants by their face they just
stand in front of the thing look at the
face they go to the class well even now
it's possible to purchase things through
your iPhone if you have the face
recognition or your cell phone whatever
it is as confirmation if you purchase
something so you can buy with your face
you don't need a computer chip anymore I
know what my face is bankrupt so I've
been able to buy anything
all right hey I hope that helps a little
bit but uh yeah I think it's mostly in
your worship and your actions there may
be something physical as well as far as
monetizing it yeah we do have a study
guide called The Mark of the Beast uh
the Bible speaks about the beast power
and the Mark it's important for us to
understand what this is we'll be happy
to send the study guide to anyone who
calls and asks the number is
800-835-6747 call and ask for the study
guide called The Mark of the Beast also
you can just dial pound 250 on your
smartphone and again ask for that study
guide the mark of the beast will be
happy to send it to anyone who calls and
asks we've got Richard listening uh from
Tennessee Richard you're on Bible
answers live uh my name is uh Richard
and I have a question about uh actually
uh good good well good late afternoon
pastors I have a question about Isaiah
66 verse 24 okay and it mentions about
Midway in the verse for their worm shall
not die I just want to know what what is
the that talk about the worm shall not
die
yeah well first of all Jesus quotes that
in the New Testament he says speaking
about those that are lost you can read
in Mark chapter 9 verse 48. it says you
know if if your right hand offends you
you just back up a little bit he says if
your eye causes you to sin pluck it out
for it's better for you to enter the
kingdom of God with one eye of course
he's using an analogy here no one in
heaven is going to have one eye rather
than having two eyes be cast into Hell
Fire where their worm does not die and
the fire is not quenched and another
time he says if you right hand offends
you or if your foot offends you that's
actually verse 45 the worm does not die
and the fire is not quenched it's also
in verse 46 Christ is quoting from the
last verse in the book of Isaiah there
outside of Jerusalem there was a dump
called Gahanna it's in the Valley of
hinnam the valley of hinnam was a place
where they actually had set up pig and
gods at one time and so it became the
dump the Jews didn't want anyone to
Revere that spot anymore and they would
fill it with their garbage and they kept
fires going in there to keep the gases
down and burning old baskets or clothes
whatever was in there so it was
smoldering and there is old fruit and
even dead animals that were thrown there
if it was an unclean animal so there was
maggots
and it's using that analogy to just say
uh you know the the fire's not quenched
you don't ever put the fire of a dump
out you want it to burn
and the maggots are eating until there's
nothing left to eat so the maggots you
know they're not killed and the fire is
not quenched
um they're just doing their thorough
work
is what it's talking about yeah and even
to add that a little bit more when it
talks about the worm actually the word
there is maggot it's talking about a
place of rejection uh it's we throw the
garbage the fire that's going to destroy
the Wicked at the end of times not going
to leave worms living in the Flames
while the wicked all being you know
destroyed with a fire the fire is going
to purify the Earth Malachi says it
turns into ashes that's right yeah so
the phrase there but it talks about the
worm not dying or the maggot it's
talking about absolute rejection of the
lost they have no hope of Salvation they
in essence cast into the garbage pit
they thrown into the dump and that's
that's the idiomatic statement we also
find that repeating job 25 6 Psalm 22
verse 6 Isaiah 14 11. so these are are
the phrases that talk about utter
distraction for rejection yep very good
hope that helps we've got Junior
listening in the Caribbean Junior
welcome to the program
so
um
faster as often referred to Michael the
archangelize Jesus Christ but they also
references I've come across in the Bible
one win Daniel white says Michael one of
the chief princes
when he came to help Gabriel and then
the other one is when
there was a dispute over the bones of
Moses Michael said
rebuke you
so I'm thinking if it was indeed Jesus
then he is also Lord he wouldn't have
said the Lord Rebecca he could just say
I rebuild you so could you elaborated
not for me please yeah well let's take
him one at a time so in Daniel chapter
10 Pastor Ross might look that up but
talks about Michael one of the first or
one of the chief uh the way that
translates in Hebrew is first of the
chief our first of the highest of the
um messengers of God the very word
Michael means who is as God and
Archangel means greatest messenger and
so the very name Michael the Archangel
means the greatest messenger who is as
God no people get confused about this
because they always think Michael is
just some you know powerful Angel like
Gabriel never refers to him like Gabriel
um it you look for instance it says and
where is it first Thessalonians 4 the
Lord himself will descend from heaven
with a shout and the voice of the
Archangel the Lord has the voice of the
archangel and that means the greatest
messenger and in Daniel chapter 12
Michael will stand up the great Prince
Jesus is that great Prince which stands
for the children of thy people who is
the great intercessor that stands for us
that's Jesus and then in Jude verse 9
where it says that Michael came to get
the body of Moses that's because Jesus
is the resurrection you might you're and
you're asking why did he say the Lord
rebuke you well when Christ was on Earth
and he was tempted by the devil he said
the Lord rebuke you so you know Jesus
does it in the name of the father that
he is rebuking the devil so
um most commentators and maybe not all
but I'd say 30 of the commentators like
Matthew Henry Adam Clark and many others
they believe that Michael is what you
would call the pre-incarnate title for
Christ and then you get to Revelation 12
and it says Michael and his angels fight
with the dragon and the dragon his
angels fought with the dragon is a
symbolic name for the devil it's safe to
assume Michael is a symbolic name for
the chief of
righteousness which is God Jesus
and the verse you referred to a little
earlier where it says that Christ when
he comes he'll have the voice of the
Archangel and then it says that voice is
the voice that raises the dead Jesus
said that it's the voice of the Son of
God the voice of the son of man that'll
raise the dead at the end so if it's
Christ's voice that raises the dead and
Jesus is said to have the voice of the
Archangel well then Michael must be
referring to Jesus yep if a equals B and
C equals B A equals c that's right let
me see you know we do have a book called
who is Michael the Archangel and we'll
be happy to send it to anyone I see your
Junior in Caribbean but you can maybe go
to our website just
amazingfacts.org and you'll be able to
read the book there for those in the U.S
uh just uh call
800-835-6747 and ask for the book
Michael the Archangel or dial pound 250
on your smartphone and say Bible answers
live Michael the Archangel yep very good
well Pastor awesome looking at the clock
we're probably going to come up on our
mid break and it's hard to cover a
question in 24 seconds but it is a good
time to remind people you do hear us
repeatedly reference the main Mothership
website of this ministry it's called
amazingfacts.org there's radio
television books videos it's everything
to feed your soul so check out
amazingfacts.org we're coming back in
just a moment
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return shortly
written by the hand of God and spoken
with his voice
some words will never fade
[Music]
Pastor Doug batchelor's 12-part sermon
series on the Ten Commandments by
calling
800-538-7275 or visit afbookstore.com
Jerusalem the city of Peace has been a
place of unending Conflict for centuries
many now believe that Jerusalem will
soon take Center Stage again but what
does the Bible say the fall and Rise of
Jerusalem presents the vital history you
need to know about Jerusalem and its
role in end time Bible prophecy this
amazing facts edition of the classic
volume the great controversy is the
perfect sharing book get your copy at
afbookstore.com
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
Bible related questions on the air
please call us next Sunday between 7 pm
and 8pm Pacific time to receive any of
the Bible resources mentioned in this
evening's program call
800-835-6747 once again that's
800-835-6747 now let's rejoin our hosts
for more Bible answers live
welcome back listening friends to Bible
answers live and for anyone who may have
tuned in along the way this is as the
title suggests a live International
Bible study and you're invited to join
us by just listening in you're also
invited to join the conversation by
calling in with your Bible questions and
the number is 800 God says we're also
broadcasting this on the amazing facts
Facebook page the Doug Batchelor
Facebook page The Amazing Facts YouTube
channel and uh
Good News television and a lot of the
stations carry these programs you might
not be able to call in if you're
listening to one of the many
rebroadcasts like our friends in
Michigan that do this in Strong Tower
radio they played all through the week
so um anyway we're glad that you're
listening and my name is Doug Batchelor
my name is John Ross and if case in case
you are listening to a rebroadcast or a
rerun of this if you'd like to call in
with your Bible question we are live at
seven o'clock Sunday evening Pacific
time so uh feel free to give us a call
and they can email questions that's
right we'll answer other times yep just
balquions at amazingfacts.org and you
can email us your Bible question
our next quarter that we have is Lily
listening in Florida Lily welcome to the
program you on the air
hi my question is should Christians
carry a
well uh if it's okay I'll rephrase it a
little bit I would say is it wrong for a
Christian that's not that uh certainly
not every Christian needs to carry a
concealed weapon but was there anything
be morally wrong with a Christian
carrying a concealed weapon
um you know Jesus is pretty clear he
said if you live by the sword you die by
the sword so you certainly don't want to
be advocating
uh you know taking of life but there's
also nothing wrong with a person having
if you're in an area where it's
dangerous and you might be able to uh
worn off
um either a predator now you know I go
to the hills I I carry a gun because
there are bears Pastor Ross has been to
our place and bears everywhere and I I
would even shoot a gun in the air and
it'll scare them off usually but there's
wild animals up there so certainly
nothing wrong with using one in that but
some people live in cities where uh you
know they may feel convinced that it it
would give them some added security
hopefully they'd never have to take
human life but it might be used to
protect
so I don't see a moral dilemma I think
every person needs to pray through that
issue but you can't use the Bible to say
you know with all that God said about
David and Goliath and the sling and the
children of Israel and
the
um Philistines oppressing the children
of Israel because they had no swords so
you can't really Advocate saying this
any moral crime in a person owning a
weapon and of course they are Christians
that are involved in law enforcement
yeah and you know they carry a weapon so
that it's a tool that's right it's how
it's used
all right well thank you Lily good
question uh Michael in Alabama Michael
welcome to the program
thank you both big time for accepting my
question uh before my question my heart
really goes out to that previous male
caller whose name the location I've
forgotten with anxiety disorder possibly
a second mental illness after he
accepted Christ Jesus
um that's a another subject for another
time that I would love to get into about
Christians with mental illness and how
curtianity has treated them over the
centuries but the thing is I have
um had two mental illnesses myself
severe depression and then OCD after I
accepted Christ Jesus I certainly don't
blame him for those the re I want to
apologize for sounding anxious while I
tried to call two weeks ago it's because
of those illnesses and because I was not
able you all had the audio turned down
within your recording studio and I was
not able to ask you if you would clarify
your answer once again this is a and uh
asking you if you would clarify an
answer you gave to a caller last May
about the um so-called mark of the beast
you made it sound as though
um and you probably didn't intend to as
though the so-called mark of the beast
um is the holy spirit
interprets any time we uh sin even if we
don't mean to even if it's unintentional
or unpremeditated or whatever as our
having a Christian having the mark of
the beast inside her or him uh now I
look in once I get what I read last time
Revelation chapter 13 Revelation chapter
13 verses 16 through 18 and I don't see
that any place please clarify that if
you would because I'm worried about my
afterlife Destiny I'm worried about uh
whether or not Jesus Christ will accept
me after I die all right well first of
all well God wants you to have peace in
your relationship with him I can't count
how many times in the Bible someone said
it's 365 times that Jesus said fear not
or something similar do not be afraid
God doesn't want us to live in a state
of fear
Jesus is our example a Christian is
supposed to model the behavior of Christ
and and Jesus had perfect peace Paul
says God gives us a peace that passes
understanding and when you accept Jesus
and you invite him to be the Lord of
your life and you keep your eyes fixed
upon him he's going to guide you and
you're going to be in the Kingdom you
just need to follow him day by day stay
in communion with the Holy Spirit now
then you ask the question about the mark
of the beast and we were saying what the
Bible says is it talks about the mark in
the hand or in the forehead let the
Bible interpret itself Moses said that
we must have the law of God and this is
Deuteronomy chapter six so these words I
command you shall be in your heart art
that's a metaphor the word of God in our
heart the law of God in our heart and
Jesus said if you love me keep my
Commandments
and he said write them for a sign upon
your hand they will be as frontlets
between your eyes and your head and in
your forehead those that worship the
Beast will have the laws of the Beast
in their hand or in their forehead so
it's a question of do you obey God or
man in the last days same thing you know
when Nebuchadnezzar told all the
children of Israel to Bow Down and
Worship his Idol that breaks the
Commandment of God are you going to obey
the law of Babylon or the law of God
same thing in the last days there'll be
a big conflict between obeying the law
of this peace power which will conflict
with the law of God and we have a lesson
on that we can sin we do it's cold the
mark of the beast and we'll be happy to
send it to anyone who calls and asks
just call
800-835-6747 ask for that study guide is
called the mark of the beast or dial
pound 250 on your smartphone and say
Bible answers live and then say the mark
of the beast and we'll be happy to send
that lesson to you you won't be
receiving the mark of the beast if you
say mark of the beast you'll just
receiving the lesson on the mark of the
beast you don't pass it like it's
important to note that the key issue in
the Book of Revelation talking about end
time events revolves around worship the
devil wants the whole world to worship
him and he uses this beast power and we
worship the one we obey so if we can
obey God and keep his Commandments we
worshiping him the first thing Angel's
message says worship the Creator if you
worship The Beast Power by setting aside
God's law knowingly and purposely doing
so we're worshiping a different power
and that's the real issue that comes to
life amen all right next holiday that we
have is Christy uh let's see Krista
listening in Idaho Krista welcome to the
program
good evening pastors evening thanks for
calling
yes Pastor Doug right quick before I ask
my question I want to share with you
that nearly 20 years ago I was quite
depressed and felt quite lost and one
night I was channel surfing came across
one of your programs and then I found
myself watching your programs regularly
and opening up my Bible and praise God
20 years later my teeth has only grown
oh praise the Lord and see I'm glad to
have a testimony that things got better
when they accepted Christ amen well we
probably sure did thank you Krista yes
not only
were programs but there were some
wonderful
Corinthians 15 29 baptism for the dead
yeah that's a great question so Paul of
course in First Corinthians 15 the whole
thing is dealing with the resurrection
some of the Corinthians were thinking
either had already happened or that um
that it wasn't going to happen and he
spends quite a bit of time talking about
that and so he says in verse 29 else
what shall they do which are baptized
for the dead if the dead rise not at all
why then are they baptized for the Dead
this is one of those examples where the
problem is more in the punctuation keep
in mind friends
the original Greek had no punctuation
the translators had to figure out how do
we break up the sentence and it's like
the uh the wife that calls her husband
and asks if she could buy something he
says no price too high well she thought
he said no price too high
and he said no price too high and where
you put the comic can completely change
it
so where you put the commas in this
completely changes it now let me
punctuate this I'll try and put the as
they say the emphasis on the right
syllable I'll try and emphasize this in
the right place else what shall they do
who are a baptized comma
or even period for the Dead
if the dead do not rise at all comma why
then are they baptized period for the
dead question mark Paul is simply saying
uh for if the dead do not rise why get
baptized for the Dead
and so it's what you would call a
rhetorical question he's using some
hyperbole here saying you know if people
are getting baptized if they don't
believe in the resurrection why are you
getting baptized if it's not for you to
be raised for the dead to be raised so
um I think this is a place where it just
gets confusing now there is one church
that believes you should get baptized
for the dead yet one person gets
baptized on behalf of someone else
that's dead
99.9 of Christians don't believe that
because everything else in the Bible
says that it's an individual's choice to
be saved
that you don't get baptized on behalf of
someone else
and so
um you know it's appointed on demand
wants to die after that the Judgment you
can't die loss and then have someone
burn candles say prayers and get
baptized for you and and save you if
you've gone to your grave with a bad
record every man will be judged
according to their works not according
to someone else's baptism
so you know once a person understands
that basic fundamental truth then you
have to say well what does this first
mean it's an issue of punctuation all
right we do have a study guide that
talks about baptism it's actually a book
it's called baptism is it really
necessary and we'll be happy to send
that to anyone who calls and asks the
number to call these
800-835-6747 or dial pound 250 on your
smartphone say Bible answers live and
then ask for that it's called baptism is
it really necessary I will send it to
you read it share it with somebody else
you'll be blessed next holiday we have
is Linda listening in Washington Linda
welcome to the program
thank you for taking my question in
Revelation 17 1 what are the seven Bulls
b-o-w-l-s yeah all right thanks I
appreciate that we're gonna yeah I think
we're gonna mute you because you've got
a little background noise there
um yeah Linda when it talks about the
seven bowls it also uses the word vials
these are containers
and um these are the seven containers
that you see in Revelation 15 and 16
where the plagues are poured out so one
of the Angels who had been pouring out
the plagues he comes and he talks with
John and he's now telling about this
great Harlot that we have introduced in
Revelation 17. is that you understand
that's right yes so the Bulls are just a
tool and it's symbolic remember
Revelation is symbolic book it speaks of
the Angels pouring out the wrath of God
upon the Earth and that is the seven
last plagues so symbolically one of the
angels that was pouring out one of these
plagues upon the Earth is the one that's
actually talking to Johnny in Revelation
17 explaining to him more details about
uh the woman by the name of Babylon now
again Revelation is not always written
in strict chronological order you have
the plagues that occur after probation
closes and just before the coming of
Christ but it doesn't always follow that
exact sequence as we have it laid out by
the chapters in Revelation usually
Revelation he's written more topical so
it'll deal with the subject pretty much
from start to finish and then moves on
to a different subject so we've got to
bear that in mind
yeah and then if you look in the Old
Testament it talks about pouring his
indignation upon the wicked and that's
in Zephaniah 3 8 and then it talks about
pouring his Spirit upon the righteous so
it often uses the word to pour things
out on a nation or a individual
thank you Linda Mexico that we have is
Phil listening in New York Phil welcome
to Bible answers live
okay thank you very much for taking my
call yeah my question is do you
gentlemen think that woke culture and
Marxist globalist ideology are connected
to the satanic One World System of the
Antichrist
yeah well in I think most of us have
kind of a general idea the word woke is
sort of still being defined by what's
going on in the culture these days
but um yeah my personal now it's you
know you're not going to find woke
Samson woke up and found out that he had
lost his power so I mean you know woke
in the Bible it's probably not going to
mean the way we're using it in our
culture today but it's my personal
belief that what we would call the the
woke agenda
is uh is not of the Lord
it's you know people are becoming um
so hypersensitive to people's uh you
know
gender feelings
that they're sort of pressing this on
everybody else and it it's just all
misguided guilt
um and they're missing the real object
of guilt which is sin and the solution
which is Jesus you know there is
probably something we can learn from
what's happening in the world around us
is how that people can be shut down if
what they are saying goes against what
is accepted as is truth in other words
the cancel culture the canceled time is
going to come when even just reading the
Bible or preaching the Bible is going to
be considered hate speech yeah based on
these parameters that they have so we
can see how all of this is going to kind
of tie together as we come closer to the
end
yeah so we're kind of bordering now on
what's Happening culturally and
politically with
biblical things so it's probably closest
we can get Phil hope that helps a little
bit
things that we have is listening
California NASA NASA welcome to the
program
I've been watching guys for a while and
I've been waiting to ask you guys a
question sure how do you know when I'm
talking to you through a dream yeah well
first of all if God has given you a
message through a dream then God will be
sure to either give you the
interpretation or bring you somebody as
he did with Joseph and Daniel that can
interpret what the dream means now God
spoke to Joseph the father of Jesus in a
dream and said the angel was very clear
and the dream said get up and flee
because herod's going to hurt the child
and God spoke to Joseph in a dream and
said don't be afraid to marry Mary
because she's a virtuous woman and um so
God then gave the interpretation right
in the dream sometimes you'll have a
bizarre dream and you don't know was
this from you know eating too much salsa
last night or you know is it a message
from the Lord
and yeah you know I just say that if God
has given you a dream
and it is from him it'll either be clear
to you or he'll send someone to help you
interpret it but he won't leave you
forever wondering why you didn't follow
the dream and you didn't know what it
meant yes and also remember that dreams
come and go they are not all from the
Lord I think the Bible says out of the
multitude of the day a person will often
dream so just things that are happening
in your life it might be a very powerful
dream you might wake up and think wow
that made a it doesn't necessarily mean
it's from God yeah and one more thought
that I just realized biblically God gave
Joseph dreams when he was young he did
not understand them until he got older
so you may just have to wait and you'll
say ah now I know what that dream meant
so
all right very good next holiday we have
is Anthony listening in Washington
Anthony welcome to the program
hey can you guys hear me we do now
thanks Anthony hey Pastor thanks for
taking my call I really appreciate it
yeah
and Pastor Doug before I ask you my
question shout out to Greg Sarita AKA
Bible flock box for introducing me to
you and your ministry oh praise the Lord
yeah we had a good time with Greg in
Poland last year
yeah I saw so I have a question that has
to do with filmmaking I'm currently
writing an action Ministry Mysteries TV
show that talks about
human trafficking and other
um heavy topics just throwing it out my
question is for someone that wants to
get into independent filmmaking like me
what advice would you like to guess
well first of all as a Christian I'd say
you just want to pray that you are open
to God's will so anything you do you
just say Lord I want to make sure I'm in
your will I I got on my knees today
about a different opportunity and said
Lord is this your will so you always
have to ask Lord what project do you
want me to work on next and how shall I
do it and just be seeking Divine
guidance is probably the most important
thing and make sure that you know
whatever you're doing that it's in
harmony with the principles of truth and
the principles of Christianity but it
sounds like you're wanting to do
filmmaking that's more of a documentary
style that will have a a noble cause
is that right
not necessarily a documentary so would
it be like a dramatic recreations
um you can say that again
um it's just a TV show that is a little
bit fictional but it does talk about a
very real and serious
World issue that we're dealing with yeah
well you just have to have like I said
the Holy Spirit needs to guide you in
that and uh you know what the it's
there's always a Temptation for
Christians to sort of drift over to the
Hollywood style of communication I do
believe you know obviously amazing facts
beliefs and producing videos and
documentaries to teach truth
um we try to stay away from the you know
just creating fictional things because I
just find a closer we stick with the
Bible and what we do know the better we
are
but um anyway it'll look for in the
multitude of council there's safety
Anthony so get good Christian counsel
and follow the word all right next color
that we have is Robert listening also in
Washington Robert welcome to the program
so Pastor Ross
and Pastor Bachelor
yes
um
I'm sure you've been asked this once or
twice
um about in Matthew 11 13 all the
prophets and the law prophesied until
John and then it seems like they stopped
or something
well they didn't in that John the
Baptist died and then you get to Acts
chapter 2 and where the holy spirit is
poured out on the apostles Peter said
this is that which was spoken of by the
prophet Joel I'll pour out my spirit on
All Flesh and your sons and daughters
will prophesy
and so God had not eliminated prophecy
after John the Baptist because then you
go to Paul and Pastor also have to help
me I think it's First Corinthians 12.
one of the gifts of the Spirit is
prophecy or one of the gifts you'll find
in the church
and so and Philip had four daughters
which did prophesy of course that could
mean they did teach too but uh yeah
you've you find uh
not only did Jesus say Elijah will come
future he said Elijah has come John the
Baptist was sort of a he came in the
spirit and power of Elijah but then
Jesus and Elijah also will come so it
seems like there'll be another
elijah-like Prophet or group of prophets
before the second coming
a couple of verses on that you mentioned
Romans chapter 12 verse 6 speaks about
the gift of Prophecy also First
Corinthians 13 Paul says if I have the
gift of Prophecy and have not love uh
First Corinthians 14 1. so there's
several it's one of the gifts God has
given to the church
so thank you and we talk about modern
psychics and astrology that's right does
God Inspire psychics and astrologers and
we that's one of our study guides we'll
be happy to send it to anyone who calls
and asks the number again is
800-835-6747 ask for that study guide
does God Inspire psychics and
astrologers we'll be happy to send that
to you next caller that we have is Eric
Eric listening from Michigan Eric
welcome to the program
uh yeah thank you guys
um my question is is trying to place
this hour that's within 17 or excuse me
Revelations 17 12 my understanding that
comes out to roughly 15 days when the 10
Nations or ten horns would be enforcing
Sunday worship internationally and I'm
not sure if I'm completely wrong and
that it doesn't belong in front of the
clothes of probation
or does it overlap the close of
probation because of the uh in the days
of Noah when there's that week after the
door was shut yeah and um you know
because the Angels would be protecting
us after the close of probation so I'd
assume the 10 Nations wouldn't be in
charge
on any commentary on that or even the
beginning of those 15 days if that is
correct all right I'm gonna let we've
got about two and a half minutes I'm
going to let Pastor Ross this is one of
his favorite subjects dive in the
Revelation chapter 17 where does that
one hour fall yeah it talks about 10
homes these horns represent political
piles of Kingdoms and then it says Thou
Ten Kings who receive no Kingdom as yet
but they receive Authority one hour as
kings with the Beast so there's going to
be a a Unity that occurs near the end
where these ten powers are going to
unite with the beast power at the end
the papal power and that's going to take
place just before the darkness that
settles upon the seat of the Beast which
is one of the plagues people realize
they've been deceived so that actually
occurs after probation closes so it's
the final movement where the world is
being galvanized together in their
opposition to God's people there is
going to be a death decree according to
Revelation chapter 13 that occurs after
the close of probation the good news is
that death decree is never enforced
because Jesus comes and delivers his
people before that can happen so those
are some of the things that have been
highlighted here when it's talking about
these 10 pounds and you're right a one
hour is about 15
um about 15 days if you do one day three
days
about that yeah and the um so there'll
be a brief period of time when the
Nations the leading nations of the world
are going to be given the illusion of
power in order to throw their lot in
with the Beast and uh they're going to
think all right you know we'll go on
together and it seems like you're
sharing power but then they realize it
was all sham it ends rapidly yeah that's
right well thank you very much you know
um I want to tell our friends that are
listening that we do have
um some study guides that talk about
revelation
and they could sign up for the amazing
facts Bible school just simply if you
call the number
800-835-6747 that is our resource phone
line if you just call and say I'd like
to enroll in the free amazing facts
Bible School they'll take care of it
I'll get your mailing address they'll be
able to send you the lessons through the
mail you'll be able to fill them out
send them back we'll actually have
somebody grade the lessons and send you
the next lesson Pastor Doug people have
said after they've gone through the 27
study guides that amazing facts has
they've learned more in those lessons in
just a few months or however long it
takes for them to do that then they've
lost then they have learned in years of
even going to Bible College I hear that
over and over again absolutely you'll be
blessed we sign off on two stages we're
saying goodbye to our satellite viewers
the rest of you stay tuned rapid fire
Bible questions on the way
[Music]
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
Bible even better than before Bible
answers live is produced by amazing
facts International a faith-based
Ministry located in Granite Bay
California
Hello friends and welcome back to Bible
answers live those of you stayed by to
take our email Bible questions that have
come if you have an email question you
want to send us just simply Bal
questions at
amazingfacts.org that's Bal questions at
amazingfacts.org Pastor Doug first
question Grace is asking who are the
kings of the Earth in Revelation 21 24
does this mean that there will be King's
ruling on the earth in the new Earth
yeah good question uh keep in mind in
the um uh in the Bible it doesn't use
the word president very often because
most of the world powers back then were
monarchies so they're talking about the
leaders of world powers it just
generically uses the word Kings right
now there are very few monarchies left
in the world there's a few
we've got a new king of England now and
I think is the king of is it Denmark and
uh you know I think there might be a few
others out there in the um Emirates well
they got a prince or answer King so but
most of the world now has Prime
Ministers and presidents but it's just
saying the leaders of the world all
right another question we have David is
asking uh all the gimmicks and the
gaffes used in magic tricks today okay
in that they're not connected with black
magic or Voodoo or one of those things
yeah well that's a good question you
know when people start doing card tricks
that's I try to stay away from that just
because you know cards are often used in
gambling and just probably not the best
association for a Christian I can't
picture Jesus you know doing sleight of
hand with his cards but I wouldn't
condemn you know people have some clown
comes to a birthday party and it
pretends to cut a banana and true and
does a trick or something as it's sort
of entertainment so um I think if you're
if you're doing a trick and you're
showing people how it is done just
because it's it's uh interesting science
that's one thing if you're trying to
deceive people
uh and getting into the smoke in the
mirrors and trying to make it look like
magic that's something different I think
that Christians ought to avoid the
appearance of evil all right real quick
cloudy is asking is there a record of
what happened between the Old and New
Testaments in the Bible
yes well it's not as thorough as we
would like it's called the
inter-testamental period but between
Malachi and Matthew you do have the
history of The Maccabees it tells about
the Greek oppression of the land of
Israel and some of the revolts and how
they got their freedom all right maybe
time for one more passage is the tithing
system something that came to an end
because we no longer have an Earthly
high priest
no Jesus endorsed tithing he said we
need to keep the priorities right but
don't neglect pain tithe Matthew 23 23
listening friends God bless we'll study
again together next week
Bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your Bible questions
[Music]